I think about your roles man I mean to
me Harvey P car was so great I
guess that was the first movie you ever
did where you were the lead like you
know it's um there must have been a ton
of dudes who wanted that part there were
a lot of guys who wanted that part and I
was definitely not high on anybody's
list for that part really yeah but I can
tell what happened was I went in there
was a thing where they said to me my
agent said all of these big namey guys
wanted to do it and but the the director
wanted to meet me and they said to me
you can't go in an audition you can't go
in and read cuz none of these bigamy
guys go in and read and I was like well
what the I'm never going to get it
if I can't read for the part and then
because it was embarrassing or something
to go in and read and so I went in and
met them and it's at some point during
the course of the thing the director
said this is a really hard one cuz we
need to see that somebody can actually
imitate him but nobody will audition for
it I said I'll audition for it I'll read
for you if you want me to and they said
great and so I I went off and my agents
were really mad at me because I wasn't
supposed to do that and I studied some
tape of them and I went in and I
auditioned for it and that was September
10th 2001 and the next day everything
that happened happened and month about a
month and a half later or something and
I just forgot about it everybody forgot
about everything you know and there was
no way that movie was ever going to get
made or anything but I was never I in my
mind I was never going to get it anyway
and then about two months later they
came to me and said they want to make
that movie they're going to try to make
that movie but none of those name guys
will do it because they don't want to
work right now because of what just
happened because they don't want to work
and I was like I want to do this movie
so it by default because September 11th
that I got the part so I got the part
because nobody else would do
it